[Musique]
les théâtres départementaux de la
Réunion s'offrent un nouveau label en
2016 le fourmis grand Galot une
appellation qui compte bien mettre sous
les projecteurs les tout jeunes
créateurs du spectacle vivant à la
Réunion oui alors bah toujours pareil
les théâtres départementaux le théâtre
chant-fleuide thére plinire ces deux
beaux établissement du département ont
toujours quand même comme mission de
soutenir les artistes et il y a les
artistes confirmés mais il y a également
ce qu'on a lancé aussi le label occupé
ouverture qualité pays sur les artistes
émergents et donc voilà maintenant cette
année on a lancé formi grand Galot formi
grand Galot pour ceux qui connaissent
pas pour même pour de trois réunionnais
connait pas le encore un peu jeune et il
y a une expression en créole qui dit FO
si f m grand Galot il mange pas haut en
gros si à un moment donné on te laisse
faire ce que tu as envie de faire tu
peux aller très loin et donc cette
notion de label de fouri grand Galot et
de donner la possibilité à de jeunes
artistes ceux qui n'ont encore pas de
qui sont pas encore structurés en
compagnie qui n'ont pas de soutien qui
s'en sont à leur première œuvre ce qui
va être le cas ce soir pour nathalina
Louise avec sa pièce euh la pièce voilà
de la compagnie de la terre sur les
mains le radeau des la pièce Le rade des
fourmis de se confronter à un public
c'està-dire du travail qu'elle a pu
faire d'écriture la la montrer à un
public et pouvoir avers cet échange que
le fourmi grand Galot c'est surtout ça
permettre un échange entre le public et
les artistes et viceva pour que
l'artiste puisse affiner son
discours affiner son
dialogue affiner
sa sensibilité et et comme ça continuer
à grandir donc se confronter au regard
des autres c'est
çaal les premières œuvres de jeunes
auteurs des spectacles d'artistes en
devenir ou tout simplement de jeunes
passionnés tous pourront par ce label
confronter leur création au regard du
public oui grand Gal c'est également ça
c'estd que moi en tant que directeur des
théates départementaux je puisse aussi
faire mon travail de de dénicheur et de
de sentir qu'à un moment donné il y a un
ou une jeune artiste don là c'est une
auteur de se dire tiens là il y a
quelque chose et il faut qu'à un moment
donné elle se retrouve face à un public
et voilà et de faire ce lien d'être le
passeur entre les artistes et
complètement inconnu vraiment
complètement inconnu et et un public et
toujours pareil sur des premières œuvres
[Musique]